hello everybody that this is the
walkie-talkie I'm sorry it's okay go go
why did you do that we're trying to get
to a cave I'm surprised stopping you I
hit the wrong button
thanks okay hello everybody we got to
move now because there's cannibals on
the way right here right now
why were they able to hear your walkie
oh god they're already here energy I
need to drink some energy drinks I wish
I had an energy during sponsorship of
some sort just so I could pull it out as
a joke every once in a while like there
are the monster like energy drink
sponsorships on YouTube I don't think
I'd want that like no it's like all the
Call of Duty youtubers like how do I
playing call of duty for hours on end
what you didn't even know how much it
was a real thing they did not but now I
do I feel bad because I know there must
be like actual gamers that really think
MLG is like serious business and I was
just like whatever it's just a joke
right I am detrimental to the gaming
community as a whole really just
bringing it wait is this good it's good
for me but it changes I am the greatest
oh I did I did a good Irish a while ago
and I could never do it again because it
was good for a second and then it was
not good you did it on stream I remember
that was it
I can't remember a good one you did I'll
shoot you but you did do one on stream
would like your last charity one that
was good that started off good and then
it drifted into just nonsense yeah I'm
sorry about that decoy I ran out of
words to say so it's made of gibberish
you know it always comes back to Lucky
Charms rainbows and pots of gold water
over there we water everywhere god
dammit again I saw water down the hill I
thought it was no no no there is water
down the hill but like it's not like
right
at my feet or anything okay so there's
water down there that's a real thing
okay where are these caves I think we're
close to one it's in some of these rocky
outcroppings they're like sometimes yeah
see cuz they're just like a small
triangle you went through the rock there
for a second I did no such thing how
dare you sir sorry
don't slap me I would never slap you I'd
hit you with ice max way did you ever
see the video of Lube it was like an
Indian game show where the girl slaps a
guy and he slaps back he goes oh she
slap I didn't see that it was like to me
I believe you know it quality means if
like a girl can't hit a guy they
shouldn't go there's a girl that's hit a
guy why can't he get back wise and then
all the guy he's just like tackle him
and take him to the ground and like make
him cry I felt bad in some ways and then
I felt bad because the whole situation
was probably [ __ ] up in the beginning
because it was some game show some
reality show or something or other
awful I have no idea what the context
was I kind of laughed and then I felt
bad that's the end of my story no but
they're definitely both you hold a
quality thing it's like a girl like
Ray's a hit a guy with like a stiletto
in the face oh god I like if they hit
them or like draw blood or something
then the guy hits back it's like how
dare you hit a woman
yeah I've seen I've seen so many videos
thank you fought for years for equal
right this is it yeah exactly it's not
because I think you know women shouldn't
be hit I don't think anybody should be
hit it's like yeah just don't forgot say
good god just be nice but yeah those um
it was another video that I saw is like
these these girls were making a video
they were like pushing this old man and
that I'm a plus no no it was like in the
middle of the street and they were just
pushing him just to try to make a funny
video and then the guy punches one of
the girls in the face they were like
really hitting this guy and instantly
all the girls like what is society
coming to yeah that's all coming back
around though the whole equal rights
thing yeah well I mean it's always gonna
be an issue
I'm not say there isn't an issue there
singing those things that obviously
aren't equal like it's in the world
today there's plenty of things going
wrong not just gender equality but
racial equality as well and all that
other stuff but yeah depressing subject
to get into so this is happy fun time to
remember how cool yeah older videos like
high-energy laughs all the time silly
fart jokes now if feminism it's really
eating a part of society that whole
gamergate thing yeah in your Irish
accent I really want to listen to you
though so it really does make me listen
and pay attention is a real that's a
real difficult thing to get into yeah
where are these kids hello I don't know
we've kind of combed the entire aisle
breaker breaker where are these cakes
don't tell us I like how it really
sounds like you're in a stadium this is
how you're in the forest at all we do it
again we built this city it's not like
it's not a megaphone I don't get why
it's doing that okay Elvis
I know yo this is gonna go away forever
and never shout again wait I saw I saw a
guy hi hi yo run away I'm some weird
monster from the woods do you think
there's tears McDonald's wears ears
Wendy's better Chipotle I always I
always feel weird whenever we mention
actual brands cuz like we're not
sponsored wait is that cave cave yeah
we're not supposed whoa what what okay
my frame rate you have a lighter I have
a tourist you actually have a torch
flashlight is you you call it I don't
have a flash silly Americans wait why is
it going to torch a torch is the thing
with fire yeah we just called everything
a torch to heaven like is that really my
fault is it really yeah you represent
America thank you I would like to do
that that would be great he's the king
of America here right did you get that
rope I did yes
oh so there's two ropes
you gay I think we need to get an
individual rope because I see a [ __ ]
bucket Shh don't have a torch yes silly
yeah I brought it up what do we do about
those guys they're just dancing yeah we
should not do anything okay so why you
should go deeper into the cave y'all
just stay there do not be alarmed we're
just gonna steal all of your [ __ ] your
[ __ ] I can't have the torch out and do
that at the same time so yeah it's hard
and tired get the joke across yeah it
needs to be funny because what we do is
funny right right you guys think we're
funny don't you
I know people think I'm funny or just
loud or they feel sorry for me it might
be a combination in three equal parts
everyone says you're the funniest person
ever it's like I am really not and just
loud it just sounds funny it's really
not funny it's it's spontaneous humor
that's not planned at all yes yeah yeah
yeah like like everyone asked me like in
the soup it's like questions so I was
like what superpower you would have he's
like would you rather be funny
or would you rather be funnier hopefully
or have unlimited money I believe god
i'd wish i was funnier god I could do
anything I wanted I'm just like very
baseline level of funny yeah Shh yeah I
saw them Danny ain't bothering nobody
they're walking towards us Danny
Danny's go put Danny took my improv
class Danny did and I want to take him
prop classes with him like he
recommended some like UCB or something
like that now I'm gonna I hopefully take
some classes down the road in acting I
want to do that oh I went in the water I
think yep where are you
those guys tonight following us a little
yeah where's the where's all their
goodies I don't know they're supposed to
be like a cave with like like chests I
gotta like swim through this area so
just follow my name I think I know where
I'm going that's not that's not what a
leader says No
that's what I Custer said when he went
off oh you know about Custer then huh
well Custer is a renowned figure in
America's long natured history burgers
for a living Custer's last stand was his
first venture into making a fast food
chain out in the West
Custer's medevac Oh Oh wonderfully the
Native Americans they've never seen
burgers or ice cream cos cos disgusted
was very good trade back in the day if
you know what I mean
so they came from miles around
unfortunately they brought with them way
too many people there was a buffalo
stampede because they didn't have cows
back then they had to get it right off
the Buffalo but straight off of there
rip it off grind it up put it on a patty
they weren't happy
the Native Americans didn't get their
burgers big fight broke out Custer may
have died maybe what he's known for yeah
maybe not so much but the last part yeah
that's still the jury's out on that the
Custer's custard stand definitely that
what that happened
you can't have a questions last and last
bit different who is Custer's last
custard stand if you know this is first
and last time that he ever made well
some say he had a few chains here and
there some say you know get a lemonade
stand out in Ohio yes correct
I go there sometimes it's actually no
I'm not joking there's Custer's custard
in Ohio somewhere I forget where it is
yeah it's like a mini mini golf place
custard cost clusters custard is a mini
fun of Custer's custard something up
here what Michael are you I couldn't get
up there what are you that's a laptop
what how do you go how do you get up
there you claim the rock is handling up
their rope you can't pick up it's a
laptop rope I wanted us why is it
getting blood-red in here yeah that's
the ocean is on fire
Oh
you let us in Ted nothing but stalactite
good good good
oh oh no we can't go that way hang on
there's gotta be there's gotta be some
goodies in here there was a reason to
come into the wilderness hello is
anybody there
REE beak over Jack over Mac is that you
where are you you say over over over I'm
in a cave it's dark can't see anything
without my torch over over and it smells
a lot like blood and feces over okay I
think we need to get out of here over
balloony we gotta find the bottom of
this and find us some natives over yeah
you gotta say over over over over okay
Hannah I got a guy torch back up
ten-four Big Momma
over coming back to your location what's
your ten six over I'm Roger I'm not
playing it anymore I'm not playing your
game what we got to do is we got to find
the bottom we got to find the weird
freaky these guys they don't have a
light anymore there we go oh we need to
go towards those people that were
standing in the shallow water very
creepily that's what we got yeah cuz
that's probably where the other people
were so we're gonna get our fare going
yeah it's probably at the bottom of this
whole place we got to go all the way to
the bottom
yeah are you like starving and
low-energy like oh yeah I'm Lorna
but I got plenty of Saudi pop and buy
plenty I mean I had one yeah yeah you
got penny that's Sodor sorter PAP what
do they call it in Ireland where did he
call me we just called up my brand oh
jeez you sit on our cider tools like
fizzy drinks soft drinks it's like would
you like a fizzy drink would you but
that's just for like the kids yeah
because you can't offer an beer until
they're 12 you know yeah we don't have
root beer or anything like that to make
it seem like hey you're drinking beer
yeah you know that's a root beer tastes
like it's I don't know it's it's hard to
describe if you've never had it it's not
like ice cream soda if I type no no no
it's it's not anything like that it's
got it's got an earthy taste
I'm please not like something they want
to drink I'm climbing her up I'm
climbing her up I'm climbing a rope wait
did you get to the promised land without
me this is in the village oh okay I've
seen a movie called the village I like
how everyone's made that joke since the
1990s and it's still funny it's still
yeah remember when he made sense when he
was next Spielberg didn't do anything
what was it unbroken or invincible no
unbroken some movies coming out soon
invincible or it was with Bruce Willis
he couldn't be hurt doesn't breakable
unbreakable that was it unbreakable not
unbroken unbreakable wait did you climb
back in the cave what are you doing up
there you doof you're a doof okay I'm
coming down I'm gonna find something I'm
gonna find one of those big freaky
creatures
okay rope burn rope burn out right now
hey it's a game you ding-dong I was
trying to sell the immersion for the
people at home they can't experience
this you think they could understand the
immersion from your accent maybe if you
stopped making fun of me they can't stop
laughing at your accents cuz they're so
funny I trying to think of what's the
most like Irish thing to say I think
like care is one of them there you go
people care not care bear care bear or
like if you say stuff like flattered oh
I'm very flattered to meet you I am
flattered actually no there's very very
Irish slang that you could get into it's
like story horse oh I went I went
underwater and I'm still walking you did
you like inception did you go deeper I
did go deeper are you anywhere near me
right now I'm behind you but there's
like a native between me and you oh you
went left
yeah keep following I'm going down
somewhere I've never been before I need
to put batteries in my flashlight well
they don't have a ding dong you can't
really do much about that baby down here
ok action man left me alone
good then get down here cuz we got
business to take care of wait I found
other guys did you see them no I didn't
see why something looks ok for a guy
who's known as like the deep voice on
YouTube you go high very like do yeah
that is that is something that I do like
I have a good range when it comes to my
silliness so oh God okay I just saw you
drop yeah what oh hey I accidentally hit
a rope no whoa okay alright there's some
weird thing here where if I go forward I
get hoarded up get down here this is an
anomaly get down on it and come in well
what's that song darude sandstorm yes I
think so I'm pretty sure I know my music
I know my music and that sounds a bit of
like a Saru dance storm Suroosh damn
storm cuz I just want to Danny's in
oh that new album is coming out soon
great I might be somewhere you sumbitch
if I could what is happening right now
yeah you're swimming that's what happens
I'm going up oh yeah yes sir why am I
not but what's with all the babies
babies help can't help you there's a
rope there go to your right there's a
little I can't which way is right am i
going underneath the underneath me
underneath me go to the jamming trying I
keep going farther away from you Oh God
okay you can't go that way just like all
the waters that I didn't get on the
outside is now on the outside of this
cave yeah Oh God okay I can see your
predicament alright and you're missing
out on the really weird creepy freezes
babies babies I'm literally envelope
right now oh there there there there
there
ah I see the Rope okay I see it I see me
on everything I can't grab onto it
how do I die i don't like dive alright
don't think you can I think it's like a
mouse thing you aim for and you go down
no god damn it I'm stuck up here now
gosh dingy darn it's a boy okay I'm
gonna die I'm on a diamond that I'm dead
are you I'm dead dying might be a good
thing I'm not dead I thought I was dead
you might be able to dry and then come
back to my name wait okay something
weird is happening right now
puberty voice yes if your voice needed
to go any deeper what have you hit a
second puberty what if that was the
thing that could happen again you turn
into Barry White
yes exactly yeah
oh god where am I going tinny echoing
you're dead I'm on the ground now hey if
you go forwards you're gonna die right
yeah if I go forward I go into the water
maybe if I enter one that's another very
interesting water it's just water
being around you I keep doing okay I
think I'm I think I'm not in the water
yet I'm not in the water
no no water where this water come from
god damn it oh okay no water I gotta
find the zones where there's water wait
wait wait the rope is like right at your
feet right now it's like the ROI yes
Oh God water right there okay so I can't
go forward this water water every way
everywhere and get that [ __ ] so why do
I do water water water water water up
there water water there's a lot of water
thank you think invisible wall do I just
suddenly start swimming and floating up
is that what you see right now Oh God
there we go
let me see if on the other side maybe
there's a not water otherwise we're just
gonna have to end the episode cuz no not
water
oh boy where am i where am i where am i
anger over the defeatist babies you
leave me I'm falling your name never be
like okay they look like sea lions with
the baby pieces and Aaron's beautiful
but I can't see him and they're all red
did you just come out of the womb no
there's a baby mixed with a leg okay I
want to see that so cool oh wait come
this way I can't there's a wall up here
well whatever it is is you guys see it
on Jack's channel or some really cool
yeah I'm better I'm like boned yeah I
keep floating up to this area where
there's the top of the water and then
I'm just stuck up here so I guess hey
guess hey let me try one last thing
before I because I didn't try going the
other side before you end you should
like die and see how far away if you
where cuz if you're close then you can
just come over and go down the hole okay
okay so sucking all this in it's like
walking into a spider eyeballs on water
there's no way through I can't do it so
I guess we got to take a look sorry I'm
trying to fix you try now it didn't fix
me I'm pretty sure all right so this is
the end of the series for now we pretty
much tapped out the force for what it is
so if you won't let us know in the
comments but we won't play probably
until there's another update so just let
other games or other games yeah well I
mean we can play games all the time it's
just about finding one that works for
co-op so thank you all so much for
watching thank you jack [ __ ]
any last words it was a pleasure love
your faces love my face too thanks again
and as always we will see you
[Music]